Congressman George Santos, the truth
challenged Republican
who grossly embellished his resume
and life experience
while running for election
was awarded
seats on two congressional committees.
That's despite
mounting legal issues and growing calls
for his resignation.
CNN's chief congressional correspondent
Manu Raju is on Capitol Hill
and some of his own colleagues
and members of the conference
are calling for him to resign,
but he still gets committee assignments.
Yeah,
because the House Republican leadership
has decided
that he will be treated
just like any other member of the House
given committee assignments.
Now, he did not get the committees
that he wanted.
Now, I'm told from Republican sources
that he had pushed
for a very high profile
committee speech
and the House
Financial Services Committee and House
Foreign Affairs
Committee, Republican leaders
decided against that and said
give him to
other committees, lower
profile committees,
than the science committee,
as well as the Small Business Committee,
but still
having committee assignments nonetheless.
Now, Republican leaders
say because their investigation
is ongoing
and a likely ethics investigation
that will take place,
they want those to play out.
If there were ever an indictment
to come down, for instance,
that's when he would lose
his committee assignments.
But there is precedent
for knocking off
people who from committee assignments
when they have not been indicted in 2019.
Stand then Congressman Steve King
made some racist comments.
Then Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy pushed to have him removed
from his committees.
But Republicans say
this situation is different
I don't
condone
what he said, what he's done,
and I don't think anybody does.
But that's not my role.
He was elected.
He represents a million people.
We're going to
treat it like any other member and you
keep an eye on it so that,
you know, there's been precedent.
Steve King lost his committee assignments
after this controversy.
What's different here?
Well,
I think it's the nature of what was said,
you know, with this feeling
like some of the things
others have said
in the past
where people condemning of other people
basically said some things about himself
So just a point of clarification
that Santa is district.
He actually represents
776,000 people, not a million people,
but that same district is a blue one, one
that Joe Biden carried by eight points.
And that is a major factor
in how Republican leaders
are dealing with that.
The last thing that they would want
in this point,
according to a number
of Republican sources,
is for a resignation to happen
that would set up
a special election,
could make it very difficult to hold on
to that seat
and tighten McCarthy's already very tight
majority in the House,
which is why
Kevin McCarthy, the House
Republican leaders,
are giving him
as the committee assignments
and saying he can be a still
standing member
of the conference for now.
Okay, Mona, Roger, thank you very much.
Let's bring in Alyssa Farrah Griffin.
She's our CNN
political commentator and former
Trump White House
communications director.
We also have Brianna Shaw,
our Republican strategist.
Ladies, great to have you here.
George Santos, Alyssa,
he is
charged with financial fraud in Brazil.
Let me give our viewers
a little bit more details about that,
that this is according to documents
obtained by CNN.
Santos admitted
to stealing a man's checkbook
that was in his mother's possession
to purchase clothing and shoes in 2008.
Santos confessed
to forging the man's signature
on two checks to purchase
clothes and shoes, costing
approximately $1,313.
Someone who is charged
with financial fraud
and defrauding
a small business
is going to be on this small business
committee.
Well, in a step further,
my understanding
is it's the first time in history
a foreign nation has asked to extradite
a sitting congressman
because the Brazil government
would like to charge him
for these crimes.
It's totally unprecedented.
We know it is the simple math
of not wanting to lose
a Republican seat,
that is having Kevin McCarthy
kind of turn a blind eye to these things.
But while they are what we consider
be committees,
not a committee
is the ones you most want to be on.
These are still overseeing
things that matter
to the American public.
I'd also note the science and technology
committee is going to be
extremely important in a Congress
that's going to be looking into big tech.
So he's going to have roles
in two influential committees
at a time
when he's under
any number of investigations.
And also just note, there's reporting
he defrauded
veterans trying to help dogs like this
man seems to know no bottom.
Now we have that reporting that
there were veterans. Their dog was sick.
This pit bull named Sapphire.
He started a go fund me
raised $3,000
though into of the pit
bull never saw the money.
The list just gets
worse and worse as we go day after day.
There's not a constituency
that he hasn't offended
or allegedly defrauded in some way.
How will he have any credibility
to question or hold accountable
any witness
who comes before other these committees.
Well already spending in this moment
he has zero credibility
because his own local GOP
wants nothing to do with him.
They actually want to send
constituent casework
not to his office,
but to a neighboring
congressman's office.
It tells you right there,
when your own people
don't want you and tell you
that you're not welcome.
Not just in their ranks,
but at any event.
That is a moment where we have to say
what kind of person
has made it
to the highest level of office.
It is a person who is, frankly,
a con man.
There's nothing about him
that seems true.
He seems to be not just full of himself
and somebody who embellished here.
He seems to be quite dangerous.
And I felt that he's
the kind of guy who will stay
and stay until he's let out in handcuffs.
Because what Kevin McCarthy
cannot grow a backbone to deal with him
because they just
can't afford to lose his vote.
And if they do lose this work vote,
Kevin McCarthy
might not even be speaker anymore.
So this is an issue where
we're looking at the situation
and we're seeing the drip drop,
but it's serving
nobody, least of all his constituents
who That leads us
to Marjorie Taylor Greene.
So, Alissa,
she is on the Homeland
Security Committee.
She's been named now to the Homeland
Let's just remind our viewers
of some of the insane things that she
has said.
A so-called plane
that crashed into the Pentagon.
It's odd.
There's never any evidence shown
for a plane in the Pentagon.
There is an Islamic invasion
into our government offices right now.
Kennedy
getting killed in the plane crash.
That's another one of those
Clinton murders, right?
We're talking about who is Keith?
I'm going to tell you what he says.
According to him, many in our government
are actively worshiping Satan
That's her following Q and on.
So she is highly susceptible
to crazy conspiracy theories.
She's in charge of our security.
I mean, and think of the history
here to the Homeland Security
Committee was stood up in 2002
after the nine 11 attacks.
When I was the former Pentagon
press secretary,
I offered to give Marjorie
Taylor Greene a tour of the Pentagon
where you can see
where the plane hit the building,
of course.
No response there.
But that is the height
of irresponsibility by Kevin McCarthy.
He could have put her on
House administration.
There's many committees
you could plug someone like her
where she can't do real damage.
But Rina said something important
that I think applies
to both of these individuals,
which is there's
a danger element here,
especially with George Santos,
a known con artist.
This is somebody that foreign adversaries
would be chomping at the bit to exploit
when you were this,
you know, caught up in legal woes.
You really don't have an off ramp here.
This is what makes you susceptible
to things like blackmail.
And he's now going to have access
to what members of Congress do.
She's somebody as well aware that
she's not demonstrated the judgment
the integrity to be on a committee
dealing with our homeland.
And finally,
one of the biggest issues
Homeland Security Committee
should be dealing with
is homegrown domestic terrorism
the Proud Boys, the Oath Keepers.
This is a woman who said that if she
if she and Steve
Bannon had led January six,
they would have won
and they would have been armed.
Totally irresponsible.
To let's look now at House
Oversight Committee,
including Rep
Marjorie Taylor Greene, who supported
Kevin McCarthy in his bid
for the speakership.
But a couple of holdouts
Lauren Boebert,
Byron Donalds,
Paul Gosar
and others are on this committee now.
There have been questions
about these side deals
that were
made to get to the final vote,
to the 15th vote to get to that gavel.
What are the next two years look like
if you have these members there on
House Oversight
Dysfunction,
dysfunction, dysfunction,
that is what the next
two years look like.
And it saddens me
as somebody who has worked
in the halls of Congress
and any of those
any of us who worked in the halls
know we know that
not only are these members, these people
we elect as our representatives,
people who should be committed
to intellectual debate,
rigorous intellectual debate,
but they should also,
at the very least, have stable minds.
And what I think we've seen
with the Crazy
Clown Car
Caucus of Kosar and Gates and Boebert
we've seen this lack of desire to govern.
We've seen this want to blow it all up.
And this is a problem
in our moment right now
where we have this
these attitudes
that are all or nothing attitudes.
They are creating the problem
that messes with everyday governing.
So it's what's happening in our politics
doesn't just happen over there.
It affects what happens on the Hill
because they bring these attitudes
and then they
they at every moment
want to create barriers to progress,
to things actually
getting done for the American people.
And conservatives
have real opportunities.
When we talk about economy,
immigration, energy.
These are places
that Republicans can lead this year.
They can legislate.
They can choose to govern.
But again, these people
who are characterizing our politics,
they've made it so hard
because they've made it so difficult
for Kevin McCarthy
to afford to lose even one vote
like I mentioned earlier.
And that is it's a very simple reason
for why we will see the dysfunction in
the next two years.